[Musique]
mais mars est le plus
était la planète la plus semblable à la terre dans le
système solaire et maintenant ce n'est plus
comme ça nous savons que mars avait de l'eau à un
moment donné nous savons qu'il
était habitable il aurait pu avoir de la vie
à un moment donné c'est  pourquoi nous y retournons
et le cherchons et il n'y a pas d'
autre endroit que nous connaissons comme ça
donc c'est très intéressant
nous apprendrons beaucoup de choses
[Musique] [
Musique]
cette mission consiste à collecter des échantillons
pour un retour futur  sur terre à
la recherche d'échantillons susceptibles d'avoir un
potentiel élevé
d'anciens signes de vie en les mettant
dans des tubes d'échantillons
puis en les mettant en cache à la surface afin
qu'un futur véhicule
ou peut-être nous, mais un futur véhicule
va venir les chercher et
les prendre  vers un
autre véhicule d'ascension qui
les ramènera sur terre
[Musique]
vous